Thanks Aaron. Thanks for giving up
lunch or whatever you're giving.
You have to be here.
Um,
I am just going to start by
introducing you to this fellow. Um,
the book is sort of arranged,
uh, with 13 species,
um, as, as their sort of focal point and,
and, and this guy's at the end. So I,
I'm giving away the end of the
book, but, but it's not really,
it doesn't really have a surprise ending,
so I think I can do that. Um, so he's a,
he's an a Hawaiian cro
or an all a law and,
um, there used to be several
species of Hawaiian crows. Um,
so they're sort of like,
uh,
which probably diverge from like the
crows you see around New York, um,
probably several hundred thousand
years ago. So it's a, it's a case, um,
a bit like Darwin's finches where,
you know,
a very small founder population
arrived on the Hawaiian archipelago.
We don't know how, cause why he's really
quite, quite distant from the mainland,
uh, thousands of miles. Um,
and then the speciated radiated out so
that they could occupy the different
islands and fill different
ecological niches.
But the difference is that actually most
of the species of Hawaiian crows, uh,
went extinct before modern times.
And this one is also under very,
very heavy threat.
And in the 80s,
the state of why realize that there
only, you know, very few left.
They took them into captivity, uh,
to try to breed them. Oh, thanks. No,
I'm good. Thanks. Thanks
a lot. Um, and this, uh,
particular bird is a bird as a male
bird by the name of, of Kenobi.
Uh, and he was born at this breeding
center, which is actually on Maui.
Uh, the bird is native
to the big island, but,
but this breeding centers on Maui
and he's a very odd duck. Uh,
as they say, he, he doesn't really think
of himself as a CHRO. Uh, he seems to,
we're not sure what he self
identifies as a, the woman who,
one woman who takes care of him,
uh,
told me that he wants a fell
in love with this spoon bill.
So He's, he, um,
will refuse to meet with any of the
females, uh, at the Mallee facility there.
There's maybe 50 females, a hundred
birds all together. Uh, and he, uh,
refused to meet with any of them,
but his genes genes are really important.
So they took him to this, uh, to the
veterinary hospital at the San Diego Zoo.
And there he came under the care of very,
very experienced a reproductive
physiologist whose was really,
who's really eager to
get, um, you know, a vile,
let's just put it this way,
of his genetic material to
take back to Maui with her. Uh,
so every spring when it's
breeding season on Maui,
she takes Kenobi on her lap
and strokes him in a way that,
you know, male crows are supposed
to find very, very exciting, uh,
hoping that he's going to deliver
so that she can take a vial,
a of his jacket back to Maui. But
at the time I visited, he had,
he had not yet delivered.
Uh, so she was still added.
And crozer are really
smart, as you know, uh,
and Kenobi can imitate human speech.
And he says, I know that's his,
that's his phrase, which is really quite
extraordinary. And, and when I thought,
when I heard that it sounds kind of
demented, he has this demented sound,
but it seemed to really encapsulate
a lot of the themes of the book.
On the one hand, uh, you know,
the incredible lengths that people
are going to try to save this species.
Meanwhile though,
all of the forces that that brought,
the Hawaiian crows to this point are
all still raging and in fact are being
increased because Hawaii,
there's now avian malaria in Hawaii.
There didn't used to be mosquitoes.
Now there are mosquitoes with avian
malaria and as the climate warms, uh,
these mosquitoes are moving
up the mountain slopes.
So there used to be sort of refuges for
some of the native birds on the tops of
Hawaii's very tall mountains,
uh,
and avian malaria is now
moving up the mountain.
So birds on Hawaii or are really,
really in trouble.
So he is sort of the emblem
in a way for the whole book.
Um, and, and he's the animal
that I end it with. So I,
I guess I was sort of step back and say,
what is the book, what it,
what is the sixth extinction?
The implication here obviously
is that there are five other, uh,
extinction events and that is true,
um,
with these are what are
called the big five,
the major mass extinctions of
the last half billion years.
And what you're looking at is time is
running from your left to your right in
millions of years.
So 600 million years ago to today.
And where you see those dips, where you're
seeing the number of marine families,
this is from the marine fossil record
and you're seeing the number of marine
families on the y axis.
And if you remember from intro bio,
a family is the level right above
a genus or species, Gina's family.
And if even one species made it
through this extinction event,
then the species is considered a survivor.
So on the species level,
the losses were much, much greater
than they are even on the family level.
And Mass extinctions are just
defined as moments in time, uh,
when the diversity of life suddenly
and very radically contracts.
One British paleontologists,
Michael Benton,
who my quote in the book uses the
metaphor of the tree of life. Uh,
during a mass extinctions he's written
vast swaths of the tree are cut short as
if attacked by a crazed
ax wielding madman.
So the first number one,
number one there that's occurred about
440 million years ago at the end of the
Ordovician period, uh, when most
of life was still in, in the sea.
So that was very devastating
to marine organisms,
but not to terrestrial organisms
because there just were no terrestrial
organisms. And number five,
a that's the most famous,
most popular if you were well,
and that is the extinction event that
didn't the dinosaurs and a lot of other
groups, um, at the end
of the Cretaceous period.
And there's a pretty broad scientific
consensus that that was caused by an
asteroid impact.
I don't have a photo I can show you,
but this is someone's best
guess of what that looked like.
So to say we're in the, in the
middle or in the, on the verge,
some people would say we're on the verge.
Some people once they were
already pre pretty deep into, uh,
the sixth extinction is
obviously a pretty serious claim.
And this claim
arises from the fact that we are,
are changing the world a very
radically in very, very fast.
So not unlike a, you know, an
asteroid impact. Uh, and in fact,
I have heard scientists say that
right now. We, we are the asteroid.
Um, so, so how, how are we doing
this? Um, there are a lot of ways,
um, I'm just gonna touch on a couple
today. Uh, we're changing the atmosphere.
You all know this. It's really a
simple stuff. We drive our cars.
Uh,
we light our homes and all of this we're
doing with fossil fuels right now and
there's 7.2 billion of us on the planet.
So it adds up pretty quickly.
And what we're doing when we are burning
fossil fuels is we're taking carbon
that's been buried,
you know,
underground over hundreds of millions
of years and we're shooting it back into
the atmosphere a very, very quickly in
a matter of centuries, quite possibly.
So we're basically running geological
history backward, uh, and at very,
very high speed. Um, and if so,
if you were an alien and
you came to Earth, um,
you could actually easily conclude,
you know,
that what we're doing
that the whole point of,
of modern industrialized
societies actually to affect
this transfer as quickly
as possible to see,
you know,
how much carbon we can get out of the
ground and how fast we can throw it back
up into the air. Uh, and if the
aliens, we're measuring this process,
they'd say we're actually doing a
pretty good, we're doing as, as, as,
as well as we possibly can. Uh, we're
increasing CRP levels every year. This is,
these are obviously our measurements
of this process. I know,
I'm sure you're all
familiar with this graph.
This is the keeling curve measuring
CO2 concentrations in the air,
once again from Hawaii,
from the weather,
National Weather Services
Observatory on Moana Law.
And,
and that a Jig jags pattern,
that seesaw pattern you see
that's at seasonal signal
because when the trees and,
and uh, plants of the
northern hemisphere, you know,
put up their leaves for photosynthesis
and the summer global CEO two levels fall.
Uh, and when they drop their leaves in the
winter, then they rise again. Uh, so, uh,
quite a recent reading,
396, uh, parts per million,
you may reasonably have read that steer
two levels hit 400 parts per million.
They did very briefly last
at the end of last winter.
They're going to again on now,
uh, you know, this winter, uh,
and then they're going to
keep rising in that seesaw.
I sort of way until they never go below
400 parts per million because obviously,
you know, we show, so no, no
signs of ceasing to emit CO2.
Um, and if we want to see how
we're doing on a longer term way,
then we can look back at ice cores.
Probably many of you have seen this
graph to a, what you're looking at here.
Once again, we have parts per million
of steer chew on the y axis time, uh,
on the x axis running once
again from left to right.
So from 800,000 years ago to the present,
you're looking at actual bubbles of past
atmospheres that were extracted from an
ice core, taken on an art, Dukkha and
all that. The Antarctic ice sheet is,
is just layers of snow that
were laid down year after year.
So we can actually see over time what
happened to the atmosphere and those Jig
Jags, cyclists that you see, those
are ice ages. Okay? So when see,
O two levels are low, ice creeps down
all the way to the island of Manhattan,
he knew,
which was glaciated in the last ice age.
And then it creeps back
up again into the Arctic.
And you're looking at a
glacial cycles there. I,
you see where people emerged
around 200,000 years ago.
And you can see that's your two levels
were never above 300 parts per million
over the last 800,000 years.
Uh, until very, very recently.
And now we're going up at what looks on
a scale like this to be a vertical line.
And if we want to go even further back,
uh,
we can tease out the composition of paths,
atmospheres by looking at
things like the shells,
a little tiny marine creatures
that fell to the bottom of the sea.
And those have big error bars.
Uh,
but it seems pretty clear that to get
c are two levels that are significantly
higher than today's.
Uh,
you have to go back to around the
Miocene around 20 million years ago. Uh,
and at the rate we're going, we could
reach those levels, uh, you know,
by the middle of this century. And if we
keep on going, uh, we could reach levels,
probably not seen it since the Eocene
around 50 million years ago by the end of
this century. So obviously, you know,
what's significant about
this is on the one hand,
sear too is just a greenhouse gas.
I'm not going to bore you, you know,
where the global warming Spiel,
cause you all know it,
but I am going to just share you this
little video, uh, that NASA has made. Um,
it's just a recreation of
global temperatures over the
last hundred and 30 years
or so.
And where you need to know to understand
it is that as the colors get warmer,
so more orangy and more yellow,
uh, the world is warming.
That signifies warmer temperatures there.
Here we go.
That stops in 2011 but,
but uh,
hopefully they'll still
updated soon because it's a
very sort of powerful visual
representation. Um, and so what
does that mean? I mean for,
for living things,
for the creatures on this planet,
you know, the, the polar bear has
sort of become the icon of, of,
of species that are endangered by
climate change because the CIS are,
Dick Series is disappearing
very, very fast. Um,
and without minimizing the problems that
the polar bears are facing. Um, what are,
what I write about in the book actually
is that it's actually likely that
climate change is going to have a much
more, even more profound effect, uh,
in the tropics. And, and there
are a couple reasons for this,
one of which is just that the topics
are aware, most things actually live.
Um, so this, in this slide you're
looking down from about 12,000 feet. Uh,
we're in the Andes in Peru. Uh,
you're looking down that ridge. Um,
and I went there with a scientist
from, from wake forest, uh,
who had laid out these tree plots.
Um,
and each plot was about
two and a half acres.
It was exactly two and a half acres.
Uh,
and there were about 20 of them arrayed
down this ridge so that each one had a
different elevation and each one had a
different average annual temperature.
And he had,
they have tagged a measured,
tagged and id the species of
every tree in these plots. Okay.
And so they had come up within
this two and a half acre,
22 and a half acre plots,
roughly 50 acres, uh,
over a thousand species of trees.
Okay.
So in the entire Canadian boreal forest,
which stretches over a billion acres, uh,
there are only about 20 species of tree.
So here we see,
you know,
in 50 acres and in an area roughly the
size of I think like Fort Tryon Park,
uh, we're seeing a thousand
different species is that
just shows you, uh, the, the,
the tropics, uh, are where things
actually were. Most species are,
that pattern is repeated over
most groups of organisms. Um,
and one of the characteristics of
tropical species turns out to be that they
have very narrow climatic ranges. So one
of the things this guy said to me was,
you know, we're going
down this ridge. He said,
you're going to see like a leaf on the
path when an interesting shape focus on
that shape. Watch as we go down the path,
you're only gonna see that leaf, uh,
for maybe a hundred meters or so, because
that's the whole range of the tree.
That's, that's the, this is
the only place where it lives.
And what they were looking at was as
the Andes warm and the is a warming,
you know, very quickly, what are
those cheese doing? You know,
they can't move obviously,
but they can see themselves at
higher and higher elevations. Uh,
and that's what's happening.
You do see a lot of species on the move,
but you also see a lot of species that
are not on the move that are just sitting
there.
So as the climate changes,
these communities are going
to clearly breakdown and,
and new ones will presumably form.
And the question of what will happen
to all of the organisms that depend,
you know,
on what's there.
Now all of the birds and all the insects
and all the mammals a is an open one.
It's very hard, you know, obviously
to track, uh, insects, they don't, uh,
they don't respond well to these having
these little tags and nailed it to them.
Um, but as, as, as this scientist mile,
someone pointed out to me
where we're going to find out,
we're in the process of finding out, we
are running this experiment. You know,
we can only run it once a,
but we're running it and we're going
to find out the answers to that.
So how else are we changing the world?
Well,
another very big effect of
carbon dioxide emissions, uh,
is the phenomenon knows
ocean acidification. Um,
I suspect everyone in this room is
pretty familiar with how that works,
but I'll just give you the basics.
Um,
and that is that the oceans have
absorbed about a third of this year too.
We put up so far that comes to
about 150 billion metric tons.
Every hour the oceans absorb
another million metric tons of CSU.
And the net result is of the acidity
of the oceans has increased by 30%.
So when CO2 dissolves in water,
you know, it forms an acid.
It's just basic. Pretty basic
chemistry, uh, is a weak acid. You know,
you drink it when you drink a coke,
but it's an acid and we are
changing the Ph of the oceans very,
very rapidly. And what the effects
of that are going to be, you know,
are also not that easy to anticipate.
Uh,
obviously marine creatures only interact
with their outside world through the
water. But one thing that
seems pretty clear as it,
it's going to impact anything that has
to build a shell or an external skeleton
out of the mineral calcium carbonate.
Uh,
it really affects sort of the
energetics of, of, of doing that.
And lots of things do that.
These are tiny little marine calcify
or is called Kaka Litho fours. This is,
you're seeing them under
high magnification here. Uh,
common shellfish like clams
or classifiers, sea urchins,
starfish,
coral reefs.
So lots and lots of marine organisms
need depend on the process of
calcification.
And one of the places,
a couple of chapters in the book focus
on marine organisms and how they will be
affected. A lot of people
trying to figure out, you know,
what the effects of ocean acidification
are going to be. And this is a really, um,
interesting sort of natural
experiment that I visited.
Now you're underwater here.
Um,
we're in the Bay of Naples in this area
where there's a lot of volcanic activity,
not, not too far actually
from Mt. Vesuvius, uh,
and it happens that there's CO2 bubbling
out of the bottom of the sea there,
uh, and, and sort of naturally
acidifying the water.
So I went out with a British marine
scientist named Jason Hall is Spencer,
who had gotten this idea that if we
looked at what happens near these volcanic
vents, we sort of have a window
into the future of the oceans. Uh,
and what you're looking at here,
I went with a national geographic
photographer and he took this wonderful
picture. And when you're looking at here
is we're, we're away from the events.
We're in a pretty ordinary Mediterranean
community. You see, you know,
there's a sea urchin there,
there's all sorts of this stiff seaweed,
which is also calcify. There's
calcifying seaweed, um,
that pink smear of pink you see
there, that's a tiny little, uh,
al algae that, that also calcifies. Um,
so you're seeing lots of lots of
different, different creatures.
They're different species there.
Uh,
and now we're moving near the events
you see this year to bubbling out of the
water. Uh, and you see what it looks
like. That sort of lunar landscape.
So this is when we get,
you know,
pretty close to the events and inbetween
he looked at every sort of possible Ph
between these two and came to the
conclusion that at the Ph that oceans are
likely to reach all of the
oceans, uh, by around 2100.
If we continue to Mitzi or
two at our current rate,
that about a third of the
species in the Mediterranean,
a dropout at that Ph, uh, they
just can't keep up with it.
So another way we're changing the planet,
and this is just the last one
I'm going to touch on today is a,
by moving species around the world,
um, everyone's familiar with this, uh,
with the problem of invasive
species. Um, oh, sorry. This is,
this is I, I skipped over this.
Coral reefs are huge concern.
Coral reefs are cows of fires.
Um,
this is just a quote from some
British marine scientists, uh,
that it's likely that reefs will be the
first major ecosystem in the modern era
to become ecologically extinct because
Carl's turn out to be pretty sensitive.
Many, many species at least a
to these changes in ocean Ph.
So back to our invaders.
This is an Asian carp.
He's been much in the news is Asian carp
is actually several different species.
Uh, they're incredibly voracious.
They're filter feeders.
They just eat through everything in
the water column, have a terrible lead,
devastating effect on native fish.
There's just a study that came out from
the army corps of engineers about what
it would take to keep Asian carp,
which are headed toward the Great Lakes.
What would it take to keep
them out of the Great Lakes?
And the Army Corps of engineers
put a price tag of $18 billion, uh,
on that one. Um, these are zebra mussels.
I don't know if people read
the story in yesterday's Times.
Are there invaders from Eastern Europe?
There are also variations for Aegis
feeders. Have done incredible damage.
Do commercial damage, stick
to everything, you know,
that they come in contact
with, uh, and really,
really have devastated native
mollusk populations. Um,
and there was a piece yesterday
about a scientist who had tried to,
it was trying to find a biological agent,
like a bacteria in this case of bacteria
or that could potentially fight a zebra
mussels. So we all have, you know,
if you have a backyard,
you doubtless have plants in
it that are not native species.
Some people have pets that
are not needed species,
but most of our non native species these
days are being moved around a sort of
unconsciously, uh, and inadvertently.
And it's been estimated, for example,
that 10,000 species are being
moved every day around the world,
just in ballast water.
And this is another way that we're sort
of running geological Lee geological
history backward and at a very high speed.
So what you're looking at here is,
um,
the configuration of the continents
about 250 million years ago when they all
crashed together and formed
one supercontinent, which
has become known as Pangea.
And then they drifted apart. I mean
to t plate tectonics, you know,
and we got the world as we have it today.
So all of these things have
been evolving separately, right?
The species in South America and Africa
and India and Australia, you know,
have been evolving separately
for tens of millions of years.
And when we bring them all together,
it has the effect of crashing this
continence, uh, back together again.
And you'll hear this phrase, you sometimes
hear this phrase that biologists use,
that we are creating the new pangea.
And oftentimes this has no particular
result when you bring species together
that had been long separated, uh, and
sometimes it has sort of, uh, uh, uh, not,
not benign result, but no, you
know, not very dramatic result.
They just sort of coexist.
But every once in a while you
get really disastrous results.
And when you think about it, if, if,
if you're moving at least 10,000
species around the world every day, uh,
you don't need a very high proportion
of those interactions to be disastrous
before you have quite a big problem.
So this is actually the,
the species that are begin the book with.
So we've worked our way sort of
from the end, the beginning. Uh,
it's a Panamanian golden frog. It's a
very beautiful animal. As you can see.
Uh, it was considered a
lucky symbol and Panama,
he used to be printed on lottery tickets,
which is rather ironic because the
golden frog and really all frogs,
uh, in Panama started
disappearing in the 1990s.
And scientists eventually figure it out.
I mean,
this is sometimes called the amphibian
crisis and it truly is a crisis. Uh,
and scientists figured out that they
were being killed by a fungal disease,
uh,
that had probably almost certainly
been ferried around the world on frogs,
by people moving animals around the world.
And one when theory,
which has not been proved.
Uh,
the one theory is that it
was moved around the world.
I'm on these things on these
frogs called African clawed frogs,
which were used as early pregnancy tests
because if you inject a female African
clawed frog with the urine
of a woman who's pregnant,
she will lay eggs within a couple hours.
So obstetricians actually used to have
tanks of these frogs in their office and,
um,
a lot of them were let go.
You now have naturalized populations of
African clawed frogs around the world.
Uh,
so one theory is that the fungus moved
on on African clawed frogs and anyway,
it was moving through Panama and it was
this interesting moment where people
could actually watch it move.
They actually could see
the frog's disappearing and
they, they realized or they,
they hypothesize that it was moving east.
Uh, sort of along this, you know, the,
the way that the river's move.
Um,
and they decided to try to
get a population, uh, of,
of these particularly beautiful
frogs and also some other species,
native to central Panama out of the
frame forest and into, you know,
some kind of protected facility. And
they didn't have any place to put them.
They went out and got the frogs,
but they didn't have any place to put them
initially. And so initially the frogs,
literally a had to be put up at a hotel.
Um,
then they built this facility.
This is the El vie amphibian
conservation center. Are,
you might be able to see some
little golden frogs in those tanks.
And this is one of the few places
that the golden frogs exist anymore,
and they're now extinct in the wild,
like the [inaudible].
There's some in zoos and there's
some at this conservation center.
So this is, I'm going to, I'm
going to sort of wrap up, um,
at the beginning of the book,
um, you could in some ways say,
you know, that this is a heartening
story. Uh, like the LLR. Um,
it shows that people really are,
you know,
concerned about other species to use
the words of Rachel Carson that there,
that they care about what Rick Carson
called the problem of sharing our earth
with other creatures. And in the
course of, of reporting the book,
I did spend a lot of time,
you know,
with people who are really devoted
their lives to this problem. Um,
a lot of them are scientists,
you know,
like the woman who was trying to
get Cannoli, uh, to, to deliver.
Um, but a lot of them are also, we're
also ordinary people for ample at,
at the El Vi, uh, Amphibian
Conservation Center.
I met volunteers who had
come down from the states.
They'd paid their own way,
you know,
they were using their vacation days to
help out because they wanted to help out.
Um, and obviously even people you
know who are not directly involved in,
in conservation give a lot of money to
groups like the World Wildlife Fund and
the National Wildlife Federation,
Defenders of wildlife. You know,
the list goes on and on. And I'd, I'd,
I'd like to sort of be able to end on that
upbeat note. You know, that if we just,
if more of us just got involved in
efforts like this, then, you know,
that would be, that would
be sufficient. But, um,
I'm going to be frank with you and say
that's not really where I come out in the
book. Um, you know, one of the
central points of the books,
really nice central point of the
book is that our involvement,
our carrying is not really the issue.
Uh,
what's really the issue or the many ways
in which we are changing the planet.
Um, and this is what makes
us, you know, comparable, uh,
in our impacts to an asteroid.
Uh, and unfortunately,
unless and until, you know, we
really confronted that fact,
the magnitude of the impacts that we're
having. And then I'm afraid, you know,
we're not really, uh, fessing up
to the problem, so thanks a lot.
Okay.
No,
Hey, uh, you showed a graph
earlier was an animation.
We showed the dividend parts of the
world becoming warm and cold and warm and
cold. And I ended with like the not
part of the globe being very warm.
Was that relative temperature?
Yes.
That is, um, off of, uh, uh, a median.
Did they choose some year? I can't
remember exactly the year, but yes,
everything is, is temperature
deviation from this, from this medium.
Okay.
So you, you talked about,
um, uh, fossil fuel use it,
that's usually the biggest shoe, but
there's also a lot happening in, uh,
in the world moving away from
fossil fuels. Um, so first of all,
are there any other, you know, we do a lot
of other stuff besides burned fuel. Um,
so are there other version a lot
of fuel, um, but is that, you know,
does that sort of a hopeful thing that we
are, are starting to use more, you know,
green energy?
It's a hopeful thing, but, you know, in
terms of actual numbers, you know, uh,
you know, we, we can go back to,
uh,
we're using more of more renewable energy.
We were also using more fossil fuels.
I mean, you know, if you just
look at admissions trends are,
they're not leveling out worldwide.
They have leveled out in the stairs. Uh,
but worldwide they're actually tracking.
I'm very high end of 'em.
There are these scenarios which people
may or may not be familiar with.
The intergovernmental panel on climate
change had these scenarios like, okay,
this is what the future's gonna look like.
Here's low and low emissions future.
Here's a medium emissions future,
here's a high, and there's the future.
We are tracking the high emissions
future. Okay. Uh, so you know,
until that graph, you
know, levels off, uh,
it on some level,
I don't want to say it doesn't
matter if we're using more renewable,
obviously it does, it's
taking away from, you know,
what that trend line would look like.
A, but until we turn that around,
uh, you know, we haven't really
gotten a handle on this problem.
Um,
so I do think it's very
hopeful. Obviously, look,
if we could convert our economy
to not running on fossil fuels,
uh, that would be huge. That
would be making an impact
or that really would be, but
I don't see signs that were, we're really
on that kind of an actual, you know,
transformative course
yet. How's that? And I, I,
I'm not alone, you know, it's like not
my pessimism. I don't think anyone,
I see signs of that at this point.
Okay.
I know,
I know this wasn't a short talk.
You've talked a lot
about the carbon cycle,
but do you also talk in the book about
nitrogen and some of the things that
agriculture is doing?
I do not get into the nitrogen cycle,
but I could have, I mean, you know,
one of their kind of interesting things,
if you want to call it interesting,
I didn't know what the right adjective is.
I could have chosen different ways in
which we're changing the world on a
planetary scale. And the nitrogen cycle
could have been one of them. Um, you know,
we are,
we fix more nitrogen and people,
you know, remember their high
school bio once again, but you know,
you need to fix nitrogen plants can't use
the nitrogen from the air because it's
bound together an end to,
so we need nitrogen fixing bacteria to
transform nitrogen into usable form.
And when we figured out,
people figured out early in the century
and German chemists figured out how to
take nitrogen from the air, uh, and
convert it to ammonia and fixed nitrogen,
that was the beginning of nitrogen
fertilizer. I, it's exactly a century ago.
In fact, we just celebrated the
century of nitrogen fertilizer. Uh,
we now fix more nitrogen than all
terrestrial ecosystems combined.
That has huge, huge impacts, you know,
on, on living things. It's why, uh,
for example,
we have a dead zone every summer in
the Gulf of Mexico cause all of that
fertilizer, uh, comes down the Mississippi
River River. It fertilizes the Gulf.
You get these huge algae
blooms, algae dies. Uh, it,
it drops to the bottom and you
have deoxygenated water. So,
and dead zones are increasing worldwide
and it's all a function of nitrogen
fertilizer runoff. So that would
be a whole other way, you know,
that we could have this conversation.
So speaking of agriculture, um, I read
that even if we stopped
using fossil fuels for power,
the agriculture that we use to produce
meat would still contribute like more
than half of the greenhouse gases but
not carbon dioxide. Different ones.
Like is that accurate?
Um, I don't think so as that,
I mean of course, you know,
our, our cows and things like that are,
are, are burping methane for example.
That's one way that that I recalled her
just produces c or two without actually
burning fossil fuels. But I think maybe
what you're referring to is, you know,
studies have shown that meat
production in general, which is pretty,
pretty fuel intensive, um, and pretty,
pretty crop intensive obviously,
uh, and also has these
other, you know, effects of,
of, of, of methane emissions. Um,
they are a major source of, uh,
of initiatives. So, you know, a lot
of people, smart people, you know,
have sort of advocated that we all eat
either a lot less meat or no meat and
that that would have a significant impact
on emissions. And I, I think it would,
it's not going to eliminate the problem,
but it would have an impact.
Hi, I'm, I'm wondering if
you've encountered a lot of, uh,
climate change deniers or human impact
deniers and if you have, you know,
what sort of arguments have swayed them?
Well, I, um, you know,
climate change denial is such a weird,
um,
sort of WWE world counterfactual
world. Um, you know,
here,
here's,
here's the graph showing you what's
happening to see what she levels in the
atmosphere. And if you notice
you're choosing greenhouse gas,
which we know we've known for
150 years, uh, and you know,
you're increasing it very rapidly
and very radically. You'd say, okay,
well I kind of expect the
world to warm up. So, you know,
we just have these ridiculous
arguments. Like, you know, it's,
it's cold in New York this week so there
can be no climate change. You know,
it just, it just, it's
impossible. People have people,
much smarter people than I have
spent a lot of time thinking,
how can you counter, you know, such, you
know, ridiculous arguments at this point.
Um, and it's very hard. I
don't have the answer for that.
But in terms of other human impacts,
you know, interestingly enough,
[inaudible] you very rarely
hear people saying, you know,
being ocean acidification
deniers. It's just really, I,
it's either too complicated or it's just,
it's just irrefutable. You know, we,
you increase [inaudible] two
levels in the air, you know,
very basic chemistry tells us you're
going to be increasing carbon dioxide
levels in the oceans. Uh, we can
measure it. We are measuring it.
The Ph of the surface waters or
the urgent is declining. Um, it's,
it's pretty irrefutable. Uh, and you
know, once again the list goes on.
We were obviously all during the
nitrogen cycle. Uh, it's not,
it's not really possible to deny that.
So the weird way that we're sort
of fixated on, on climate change,
yes or no, I think is
a complete, you know,
function of a bunch of,
of,
of increasingly battled,
you know,
just information sources which have
been funded by all the usual suspects.
I mean, all of that is
true that you read. Hi,
thanks for coming to speak with us today.
Um,
that picture of the stark differences
in what the ocean looks like is almost
enough to make someone want to cry.
And it should,
I think there are a lot of smart people
who realize that change is happening,
but it feels so impossible
to make any change happen.
And I guess my first answer or my first
question to you would be what could
change things? But I guess in
thinking about my question to you,
it's more a question of do you think
there's anything that will change this
trajectory and what would that be?
Because it,
it feels almost like an
insurmountable issue. Well, I mean, I,
yes, yes, it does feel that
way. Um, I think, you know,
one of the reasons I,
you know,
I'm glad to be here and talking to
you folks at Google is because, um,
you know, Google has been, you know,
they're very smart people at Google
who are very aware of this problem and,
and know what it takes to, to, you know,
for Trans transformative
technologies to enter our world and,
and, and, and,
and really change the way we think
about things and the way we do things.
And I think that that is,
you know,
one possibility there is one possibility.
I mean, some gentlemen said before,
you know, we, there are,
there are renewable sources of energy
out there that are increasingly being
deployed. And that is true, not in
a transformative way at this point.
Um, but it seems to be not impossible
that that could happen. Uh,
if very smart engineers like those, you
know, a Google put their minds to it. Um,
it seems to me that that is a possibility.
I am not an engineer,
so I don't claim to know
what that's going to be. Um,
but you know, there are very,
very, very big forces at work here.
There's 7.2 billion people on the
planet. A lot of people, you know,
want to raise their standard of living,
which unfortunately right now, uh,
you know, tracks global GDP and
global carbon track each other.
And until, and unless, you know, we
uncouple those or decide, you know,
to have a lower GDP, uh, you know, we're,
we're in this cycle where emissions
are just going to keep going up.
Impacts are just going to keep
increasing. And, you know,
I certainly don't claim to have the
answer how we're going to break that
connection or if we're going
to make that connection. Um,
but it doesn't seem to be
impossible that that could happen.
I,
I'm curious
about the, uh, besides for
domesticated and invasive species, uh,
what kind of animals or species are
benefiting from human impact? And,
um, is that change in scope
or population count? Uh,
is that a big effect relative to the
first order effects of human impact or,
that's true. That's a
really good question. And I,
I don't have a great answer for that. Um,
that it's a really interesting question.
I mean, you know, people
have, you know, for example,
rats seem to do really well,
you know, uh, you know, all the,
all of the species that we know
benefit from human disturbance, um,
you know,
seem to do really about,
so rats have been taken around the world
by people. They are now on islands. Like,
you know, like the Hawaiian islands
where they never were Hawaiian ons,
had had no mammals.
Uh,
they're on really tiny distant islands in,
uh,
the Alaskan peninsula where people never
bothered to settle the date they left
rats and you know,
so Roger everywhere.
And one of the guys that I went out
within the book or British geologists, uh,
sort of speculating and it was tongue in
cheek, but only half tongue and cheek.
You know, that, that rats will inherit
the earth. That, that, that will be, uh,
in become sort of the dominant,
you know, group. And I,
but I think it is a really interesting
question because clearly, yes,
echo space that's being emptied,
you know,
by other species may or may not
be being taken up, you know,
by species that that benefit from human
disturbance is not, it's not clear that,
you know, your total biomass is always
going to remain constant, you know, so,
so I'm sure there were people
doing interesting work on that,
but I can't give you any
great statistics on it.
Clearly. Also domesticated
animals now make up, you know,
a phenomenal proportion of
the world's biomass. Well,
if there are no more questions,
let's thank the speaker again.
Thanks a lot.